hi my name is Rudy Shah and I'm from the
University of Waterloo
my talk is called a new model for
quantum cellular automata and in my talk
I created a new model for quantum
cellular automata that evolves a tensor
product of qubits and there's
interesting results
hello everyone today I will be
presenting to you my summer school
project which was a new model for
quantum cellular automata okay so the
four the top barcode image is a recent
Pripet a preprint of the paper that my
mentor and I published following the
months of the summer school and the
bottom barcode is the function
repository function that you'll need to
make this presentation work if you're
looking at it unpassable also huge shout
out to Jonathan Gerard yeah I couldn't
have done this whole thing without him
so yeah okay so what is a qca
a quantum cellular automata so it's just
like a classical CA where you have
logical gates applied onto classical
qubits you have in a quantum CA you have
quantum gates applied on to quantum bits
or qubits in my model I evolved a tensor
product of qubits and I use unitary
operators to evolve that tensor product
okay so let's do a quick overview of
quantum computing so let's say I have a
qubit and I'll call it Sai so I can
represent it like this where the norm of
a squared is the probability that the
qubit is in state zero and the norm of B
squared is the probability that it's in
state one now let's say we have two
qubits sy one and side two so I can
either show them like this separately or
I can take a tensor product of the two
things and I'll end up with something
that looks like that where each of these
coefficients represents the norm squared
of each of these coefficients represents
the probability of the two qubits being
in that given state and this all these
coefficients when you put them in a
vector that's called the state vector of
these of this tensor product and that
that state vector is what I evolved in
my qca okay so let's say I start with
three cubits
for example so this is what my initial
state would look like and I have eight
coefficients as you can see okay so now
I want to evolve this state so I'll take
an operator U which is any unitary era
t2 unitary operator and I'll put in my
first two qubits in it and I'll get two
new qubits out of that and that'll be my
intermediate size 0 1 prime state then
I'll take the next two qubits and so Q 2
Q 3 and then Q 1 and Q 3 and then I'll
add all of them together to get my new
final sy 1 state okay so I can write
this big U as this sum of all these
little use and let's see if I have more
than three cubits I can show it like
this and if I have more than one
Operator let's say I want to have em
different operators so I want to apply
you and then another you that are all
different than I can write big you like
this so for an arbitrary state P I need
I just need to apply big u P times on to
sy not to get my sigh P there is a note
I'd like to make about enumeration so in
Steven Wolfram's classical cellular
automata he has a way he's like a finite
number of rules that he can apply but if
but in my Q ca'se I'm just all my
operators are just unitary matrices so
if you have a way of enumerated unitary
matrices please let me know because yeah
I don't know how to enumerate those yet
okay so here's an example this function
quantum tensor automaton is in function
repository and if I start with four
cubits so I'll have to the 4 or 16
things in my state vector and I'll just
evolve it for one time step and I'll end
up with this but I don't really know
what to make of this so Stephen Wolfram
had like these black and white things in
his CAS but how do I show a complex
number
so I had to come up with some visual
visualization scheme for that and this
is what I came up with it's not the best
but uh uh if you have any better ideas
please let me know so the red is a 1 the
pure green is like a negative one black
is zero and so on and any complex number
is just a composition of these colors so
if I apply now if we can see this better
I guess maybe if I apply this random
unitary operator on to this initial
State for 10 steps this is what it's
going to look like let's look at some
more examples this is another random
unitary operator and another one as you
can see there's like patterns or like it
looks like oh it's repeating itself but
then sometimes it's not repeating itself
it's got like little fluctuations so I
wanted to actually get numbers on these
things so I did what almost every
physicist does with a state vector I
took the norm squared and I plotted
those over time so I prodded the
probabilities of being in a given state
over time and here's what I got so as
you can see when I start off with any
initial initial these are all six random
unitary operators and I start off with
an initial condition and they all reach
an equilibrium state which is pretty
interesting I think yeah when I show
this to physicists they were like yeah
the system yeah you're applying a
Hamiltonian so the system reaches
equilibrium but when I thought about
what I actually did which is just
multiply a matrix with a vector a bunch
of times it didn't really make sense to
me it was really weird and interesting
so this was a cool thing that I found so
what next well I could change the
initial conditions I could change the
operators see how that affects it
I could try connecting it to the real
world pretty much do everything that
Stephen Wolfram did in nks I could do
with this model so when I showed this to
my mentor Jonathan he came up with a
conjecture or a way to connect it to
the real world and this was it so here
is something from Leonard Susskind work
alice falls into a black hole Bob sees
Alice get redshifted he attempts to
reconstruct her from the redshifted
State the computational complexity
required for Bob to reconstruct Alice is
related to the time taken for Alice to
fall into the black hole in Bob's
reference frame so the way that this
connects to Mike UCAS is that for
example I start off with an initial
state and that's my Alice she falls into
the black hole and reaches this
equilibrium state which is her
redshifted state so the amount of
computational complexity required to
start with that equilibrium state and go
back to initially Alice would be that
computational complexity so the time
taken to reach that equilibrium state
should be somehow related to the
computational complexity required to go
back to Alice starting with the thermal
ice date and so I began I tried to prove
or we tried to prove this conjecture
over the following months over the
summer school after the summer school
okay so first off equilibrium time how
do you measure the equilibrium time of a
given Q CA well I just did it in the
most obvious way that you could I looked
at the norm squared and I said okay when
do these stop changing or when is the
difference smaller than a given
threshold and the number of time steps
that it took to reach that to for that
difference to reach that threshold that
was the equilibrium time I think my
threshold was around 10 to the negative
12 I believe yeah and I did this for a
hundred different initial conditions and
fifty different operators and here's
what I got so the blue is the mean and
the yellow is a standard deviation this
graph right here is averaged over
initial conditions and this one is
averaged over operators so as you can
see the equilibrium time greatly depends
on the
operator but doesn't really care about
the initial conditions which is pretty
interesting now you may look at this
graph and wonder what that giant peak
right there is doing and I wondered the
same thing so I looked at it and this is
what it looks like so you can also see
things like resonance in these queue CAS
where if I evolve this operator for like
eight hundred steps it'll reach
equilibrium whereas the ones previously
that I showed only took like about fifty
so this resonance feature is really
interesting and we're still not sure why
certain matrices show this type of
resonance so if you have any ideas let
me know another thing I looked at for
the equilibrium times is the rate of
convergence so how fast does a QC reach
its equilibrium and we found out that it
was exponential yeah and this is a plot
of the change in the norms over time
okay so now on to the complexity so the
computational complexity this was a
little bit trickier but yeah so given
this equilibrium state Bob needs to
multiply this equilibrium state with r
to get the initial Alice state and the
condition that we imposed on this R was
that any R that is hermitian and the
reason we did this is because given the
what physically what the scrambling
complexity is is how convoluted does the
measurement apparatus need to be in
order to measure the equilibrium state
as the initial state but another reason
we had to impose this condition is we
couldn't if we impose that our was
unitary it took way too long for fine
instance to find and our that was
unitary so we we said okay hermitian are
also kind of makes sense and then after
you find that are you can add over the
norm squared of the eigenvalues and
that'll give you your complexity and
then I do the same thing I did it for a
hundred initial conditions 50 operators
and this is what I got on the right
again
averaged over initial conditions on the
left operators and you can see that
similar behavior that the operator again
largely determines everything so that's
that was like a big takeaway from this
like the operator largely determines the
equilibrium state you the equilibrium
time and the computational complexity
which was interesting and now came the
time to relate the two and we got a
nonlinear relationship with an r-squared
value of 0.9 3/4 which was pretty good
but again this can also be greatly
improved by again maybe imposing that or
is unitary finding different ways to
calculate complexity and so on so yeah
those those are also the next steps so
maybe collect more data to improve that
r-squared value improve the complexity
analysis we can also validate more
conjectures all of this is also written
at the end of our paper if you are
interested and that's it I'd like to
thank you for listening to my talk and
I'd also like to say that I am looking
for a job from January to April so if
you have anything available please
contact me thank you that is all
[Applause]